hello everyone and welcome back to the
2019 Tata Steel chess tournament it's
around 12 and we haven't shown any games
from around 11 I said I will not be able
to show any as I was off to that party
but well some interesting things have
happened for example Samuel Shanklin
resign resigned his game in a drawn
position against onigiri which well once
again put on Yuri tied for first place
with Magnus Carlsen so that was a very
interesting not something that happens
every day but here crossing faces faces
with one beat the white pieces yung shue
stop Duda oppose run master and it's
quite quite an interesting game I do
hope you enjoy it so without further ado
let's just check out the disorganized
game and then we're gonna talk about the
standings and what happens in the final
round
so crossing opens with d4 we have Knight
to f6 c4 e6 Knight to f3 and d5 the
Queens gambit the client is on the board
Knight to c3 and now D captures on c5
accepting on c4 we have E 4 by Carlsen
opening up a discovered attack from the
bishop to the pond we have Bishop to b4
pinning the knight and Bishop captures
so as the knight on c3 is pinned Duda
can now capture on e4 which he does we
have Knight captures on e4 we have
castles and now Knight to f6 this
position has been reached in I believe
over 200 games in in the database and
the most often often move here is Knight
captures on c3 but here after pawn
captures there's a well not all that
much you wanna do you can even go back
because if you go for something like a
bunch of captures on c3 and want to go
grab material white can either go up to
be one but even the 3/3 is a very nice
cutting off the black king from castling
here you would give up the exchange but
with the bishop pair and the King stuck
there and unable to castle it would be a
better position for white
so after this castling do that goes back
with the knight Knight to f6 and here
Queen to a4 check this is still known in
theory nice to see six defending
the shop and now nicely 5-wood a double
attack against the night here so rook to
b8 and now comes well we could say this
position was reached last year in Aldi
box Norway championship 11 RN and had a
white pieces against Fabiano Caruana
where he attempted the d5 and that was a
really intense game but ended in a draw
here Carlson goes to look after the one
and this is not a completely new game
after after move 10 so here we have
castles and now Knight captures on c6
pawn captures and now Queen captures on
a7 instead of on c6 cross and decides to
keep these two double CC pawns later as
easy targets targets Bishop to d7 and
now Queen goes back Queen wants to go
back all the way to C 2 we have c5
opening up an attack against call since
Queen Queen to c2 and now C captures on
d4 rook captures and now taking
advantage of this rule being on the 4th
early maneuver the bishop - to a much
better square C 5 and that will pressure
the f2 pawn and cousin goes root 2 H 4
so I very nice Rock lived by Carlsen and
you can see that the h7 pawn is really
feeling the pressure if this night
wasn't here queen h7 would be checkmate
so Duda wants to alleviate the pressure
he plays h6 and this is where the game
really takes off
Carlson develops with with a great tempo
he plays Bishop captures on h6 starts an
attack against dudas king and what do
you do here you don't have to capture it
is the best move we have captures and
now not rook captures if you capture
with the rook immediately King g7
attacks the rook prepares for the other
rook to enter the game for example rook
h4 Brooke h8 and your piece sacrifice
will be in vain
so after G captures on h6 we have Queen
to d2 now preparing to create this
powerful battery along the H file it is
not possible to defend the h6 pawn so do
defines a different plan we are 92 h7
Queen captures on h6 and now how do you
prevent Queen captures on h7 checkmate
you can't move the knight because you
then you get Queen to h8 checkmate
so not really not really a lot of moves
you can do but there is one move that
saves you from getting checkmated I'm
sure we all see it
it's Bishop captures an f2 with check
either White will move and then lose the
rook or you will capture an f2 which was
played in the game and then comes Queen
to f6 check you force a trade of Queens
we have Queen captures not capturing
immediately first you grab the b2 pawn
with check Carson has to move the King
King do you want and now finally Knight
captures in f6 and here we have rook to
f1 cross and wants to go rook f3 rogue
g3 and ended the game immediately if
possible but of course such things are
not don't happen very often in chess so
King to g7 making room for the rook to
come to the G file we have looked at
three and now again you do have to be
careful if you play something silly like
Roxy to then route g3 indeed dd-does win
the game you have to block with the
knight give up a piece and then you just
lose so after rook to a3 we look to g8
now making room for the King on f8 rook
H to f4 and again a Duda has to make a
choice how do you defend you can add to
defend the night if you move the knight
you'll lose the f7 point so here dude I
decided to give up two pieces for the
rook there was a one interesting choice
although it's not all that great he
could have gone King h8 and allow rook
captures on f6 for this rook captures
and g2 check but after King moves and
rook captures here yes you are
threatening checkmate but after rookie
King he won white defends everything and
now you're just down a piece and white
white would be better here any any
checks black can go just rook f1 and
everything will be alright so after rook
h2f or do they decide to go rush of the
c6
attacking the rook here and causing the
decides to give up the rook
we have rook captures on f6 Bishop
captures on f3
rook captures on f3 and now rook to d8
so here as you can see Crossan has both
first half three points but constant has
a bishop in the night for a rook but
while that is an advantage it's not all
that easy to convert another
into a full point so let's see what
happens first rook F to Carlsen offers a
trade of rooks do that the clients I
work to be four attacks the bishop and
now Bishop to b5 we have looked to a
eight pressuring da file and now a four
and okay it's a very nice position we
have c6 you can't really capture here
because rook c8 and your bishop and also
night are attacked after the bishop
moves
so after c6 Bishop to e2 and now comes
Luke to a5 stopping that pawn on a4 and
waiting to see what Carson will come up
with we have rook to f3 now defending
the knight and c3 and it's very
important for whites the first make
everything work you know just put every
piece on optimal square the rook is
controlling the night protecting the
night the night is protecting the pawn
here and well now white can think of
ways to improve the position we have f5
by Judah and now King to have two across
and brings the King into the game Luke
the c5 and now comes Bishop to d1 now
the bishop is also defending gay for
pawn so now the knight from c3 can move
we have E 5 nights to e2 and now King to
f6 we have looked to a3 perhaps now da
pawn can start marching forward
rook to be one attacking the bishop King
te one defending and now efore we have
g3 by crossing taking more control of
the f4 square if you started with a 5
immediately pushing doesn't really work
you just go rugby to be 5 and a 3 6 or
okay 5 captures captures and now you're
gonna lose the pawn as the bishop or
Knight or helpless to defend it so after
a for g3 like we said King to e5 and now
comes h4 causing the sella past h1 and
also a passed a pond but to do that also
has a past a pond and the past C pawn
what goes in Carlson's favor is that a
and H are outside pass pawns
so look to a5 blocking the pawn and now
h5
Duda also starts pushing the pawn we
have c5 and now we have kink to d2 by
Carlson if you try h6
doesn't really work again roof to be six
you can go age seven but rook to h6
again you will lose this pawn so after
c5 we have King to d2 by Carlsen we have
C 4 and now King to c2 attacking the
rook rook goes back to be 8 and now King
to c3 and now do that doesn't allow
cross in such activity with the King he
forces him to go back we have rook to be
one attacking the bishop and now King
goes back King C to Luke back to be 8
and now King to c1 and now Luke to b6
now this rock is controlling gape on
this rook is not allowing this pond to
go any further again do tasks Carlsen
how will he proceed
we have Bishop the c2 by Carson now
comes Luke the d6 and now Knight to f4
simply putting pieces on more optimal
squares rook the c5 waiting to see what
Carson will do we have rook to e3 and
now comes King to d4 here an interesting
idea for fer Duda was c3 taking more
squares here from Carlson's King but
also in some lines perhaps getting rook
all the way to d2 was a possibility but
Duda goes for King too before he
increases the activity of his King but
now cousin was the rook we have rook to
e1 and now rook to h6 and this is the
position where the famous Norwegian
supercomputer says a said that white is
winning here and came up with this very
fancy diagram which I also shows on
Twitter there you have it this is a this
is trend in this position so take the
rook from e1 and make it go all the way
from g6 so we can show it here says his
plan is a rookie to the d2 forcing the
kicking back for example to e5 then go
all the way up then here then here and
then either force a rook trade or if the
King perhaps ends up on e5 then maybe
even rook to e6 threats of checkmate
will be possible but you know it's
always easy when says a point set out
cousin goes King to D to cross and finds
a different plan we have looked to e5
and now comes night Stewie to check
forcing the King back King c5 and now
rook to h1 defending his h5 pawn rook
back to 8th and now comes King to c3 now
the king is very
to finally on c3 and out rook to g8 and
here cousin takes a well advantage of
the awkward placement of and the rook
that is attacking the h5 pawn by playing
rook to be one and this is cousins plan
he finally is able to give up at the h5
pawn because he grabs a more material
elsewhere do the plays rook captures on
h5 it is the best move and now comes the
bushel captures on e4 and now you can
see that the rook is not all that
greatly placed if pawn captures Ruby
five check picks up the rook kinky sex
rook captures on h5
so after bestial before we have rook e8
attacking the bishop now we have Knight
to f4 attacking the rook on h5 rubgy
five and now rook to b5 check King to d6
and now Bishop captures on f5 and now as
you can see Carlsen grabs a material but
we have rook a person g3 with check King
to d4 and now comes a rook to g1 so it's
still one point each but now this point
can be pushed and this point is in
danger
rook the b6 check King to e7 and not
Knights the g6 check 90 d5 check is also
possible but then the King escapes or
you know if you go here then you can get
check mated in one but constant decides
to go for 96 check forces the King
backing of seven and now simply wins the
pawn we have King to g8 and now comes
Knight captures on c4 rook to e8 going
after Carlson's passed pawn and now
comes a five the knight protects the
pawn rook to a one and now comes Luke to
b5 the point is now nicely protected
rook to e7 and here we have Bishop to e4
if King c5 is simply trying to get to
the king up and win the game then rookie
six you block the king but then rogue b6
and here you would have the option of
playing rook captures after Knight
captures Bishop captures and now it
doesn't really matter what you do Ruby
five characters captures and it's it's a
draw by insufficient material
so instead calls and finds a different
idea Bishop to b4 we have rope to c7 and
rook to f5 cutting the King off from
approaching the position we have King to
g7 and now Bishop the c2 making a plan
to get the King here and block the a
file with the night and hopefully start
pushing his pawn
we have looked the c1 attacking the
bishop King to c3 and now
Duda I believe was let in less than a
minute on the clock here and while there
aren't all that many moves dude I can go
here for here you could try rook
captures here an interesting idea but
after pawn captures the rook captures
with check King b3 it doesn't work
because the black king is simply cut off
from the position the white king will be
able to escort the pawn up the board and
it's it's a winning game for white even
though it seems a doula can grab a lot
of material here so do the try it
rook to have seven but across and simply
captured it we have rook captures King
captures and here cousin immediately
played knife to a3 which will block the
rooks control of the a file the King was
simply defended from before you can go
Bishop to b3 push the pawn and it's all
over and with the black King being so
far away from the action there are no
chances of drawing this game yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoy this from
around 12 of the 2019 Tata Steel chess
tournament as I mentioned we do have the
standings so I don't forget here they
are after 12 rounds Magnus Carlsen with
so lead eight and a half out of 12
without a single loss I believe there is
one more yeah ding leer and also in
fourth place with 7 out of 12 also
without a loss but a point and half less
than Magnus Carlsen onigiri with 8 out
of 12 in second place
Napo with 7 out of 12 and third like we
said a tied with ding leerin and also
Vishwanath on under then with 6 and a
half video jarate with 6 we have Timur a
jog of 5 and a half is shared with
Samuel Shankman and Richard report
young shift of Duda with 5 now after
losing to Coulson
Vladimir Farah seven chakra are four and
a half out of 12 and
Georgian when forest and Vladimir
Kramnik sharing last place with four and
a half
Oh all four of them are sharing okay all
four of them sharing wood four and a
half out of 12 and Kramnik even won his
last two games so cramming drastically
improved here so there's a one more
round to go in the final round for the
title for the you know winner of the
2019 Tata Steel chess tournament it will
be uneasy Geary versus Magnus Carlsen
Coulson will have the black pieces and
as you can see Crossing is already a
half a point up Geary will have to win
against constant you know claim in the
title
there is no other way forgive it to do
it
so you know I believe yeah I mean yeah
there's no other way or no one else can
even get close if yeah if anyone on and
England or nipple wins doesn't really
matter they're just tied with Erie so
yeah it must be done either Coulson will
win or gear when there's and I don't
think we'll even see tiebreaks so
definitely tomorrow is is after the 13th
game it's over yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Mitchell Kirchner Noah Kirby
Pollock slow-mo Christian Kim
keone and anti pavilion and for a
contribution to my channel thanks a lot
I really appreciate it as usual you can
check - on my previous videos see our
think all for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content thank you all and
have an excellent rest of your Saturday